what's up everyone welcome to the video
today we're going to take a look at how
to change the battery in this dodge
remote key fob
this dodge key fob is going to use
replacement battery
CR2032 and I'll put a link in the
description box of this video to where
you can purchase this battery if you're
in need
so the first thing we want to do is
remove the emergency key that's in the
bottom of the key fob
that's done by pressing this release on
the back that my thumb's on and then the
emergency key will pull out like that
now what I'm going to do is grab a
flathead screwdriver and if we look at
the bottom of the key fob
this is the slot that that emergency key
slid out of
just below that we see this Notch right
here
what I'm going to do is put my
screwdriver in the notch like that and
then I'm going to just push it all the
way in and then I'm going to twist it
like I'm opening a lock with a key
and as I do that it splits the two
halves of the shell apart
go ahead and pull the rest of the way
apart with your hands like that
then in the back of the shell we see our
battery right here
and if you grab your screwdriver there's
a little bit of a cut out in the holder
you can get under the edge of the
battery and get it out of there
grab my new battery and we want to make
sure that we're installing that with the
plus side down
like that
snap the new battery into that holder
and then we'll snap the two halves of
the shelves back together
make sure they're all the way snapped
together
slide our emergency key back in
and that's it
if you could take a second to like And
subscribe it helps us out and I'd
appreciate it
thank you